[Music]
all right let's go
to john in atlanta georgia john what's
up man
hey dr d how are you i'm awesome hey
listen
so inside baseball
what in the world happened last time we
were supposed to meet you're supposed to
be on the show
a few shows ago and what happened
well i was trying to be a good citizen
since i'm a firefighter um and uh
didn't want to talk while holding the
phone uh in the car and i'd
try to pull over quickly and uh forgot
that i had a trailer on the back of my
truck and
sideswiped a car it was awesome
you got so it was your fault 100 my
fault
oh man are you okay oh it was it was
like a fender bender my the wheel well
of my trailer just went into their door
and
caused enough damage that the police and
of course my firefighter buddies had to
come and make fun of me and
it was awesome oh that's outstanding so
this call is costing you thousands of
dollars right
well luckily enough my deposit was or my
deductible is only 500 but i'm sure my
insurance will go up so yes
but you're worth it i suppose i'm going
to get
you know you'd love to say that this is
the advice is worth what you pay for it
and you always say that it's free so
this is not the case
oh man i know i'm gonna have to ramp it
up a notch dude you
like uh man well i'm glad you're okay
and i wish you were a better driver
because now i feel all nervous about
this call
i can't screw this up you're a
firefighter you actually help other
people
and you're clearly not a nascar driver
which is a good thing
all right so john how can i help what's
up okay brief synopsis is uh
i met my wife and we started dating a
little over three years ago
and then we've been married just about
two now
um and while we were dating and then
subsequently engaged
she went on to tell me that she had
suffered from anxiety and depression
um but you know we weren't living
together so i didn't get to see the in
and out we weren't living together until
we were married
i didn't get to see the ins and outs of
every day um
and right as we were about to get
married maybe
two weeks beforehand she kind of alluded
to that it was much more than she had
let on um and provide sort of provided
me an out was like hey if this mental
illness is
worse than i've told you about is that
something you're gonna be able to handle
and if not
i'd understand if you don't want to you
know go through with the wedding and
we were getting married in two weeks and
it was a destination wedding and people
um had already had their tickets and
everything was paid for so i mean what
am i gonna say at that point like nope
let's not get married
um uh and then hold on let me stop right
there
did you ask for more information then
if i were to just hug her did you just
hug her and like have a
notebook moment and then say i'm with
you forever and it'll be fine
pretty yes pretty much that i in
it's how i feel now is that like that i
mean 100 i was in then
if i'm gonna if i want to spend the rest
of my life with her i want to spend the
rest of my life for better for worse
that's right um so i did not pry no um
and i felt that honestly if it was on
her heart like when god put on her heart
to divulge all that it was
that would be in her time i didn't want
to push her to
tell me more um in retrospect i probably
wish i would have a little more um
because it was almost like once we got
married a switch
sort of flipped uh i i can definitely
correlate that to living together
obviously you see a whole lot more of
people um
inside that you don't normally see and
then the fights just were
uh i mean full disclosure is that i was
not i'd like you to say all the times i
did not have the tools in my toolbox to
lead my way through this but the fights
to me were just incredibly illogical
like we would argue about things that
and i've been married before this is my
second marriage so i know what it's like
to be in a marriage where
little fights happen over nothing but
this was beyond anything i'd ever seen
one fight got particularly bad that i
had to involve her mother in
um his mother went on to did you yeah
oh because i was worried about her
safety to be honest with you yeah but
eat all right man when you used to no no
and
at one time i let me back up too this
was also uh
at her suggestion which was
hey i think you should talk to my mom
about some stuff that's going on she
could probably help you
navigate this so this was at her
suggestion also
um and at that fight her mom basically
said mandy i think it's time to tell him
the full truth of what's going on
um and that full truth hold on so her
mom knew that she had been
holding things back from you and lying
to you before you got married
uh i don't think necessarily she knew
that i think it came out
in this big in that big fight that i'm
referencing that you had no idea
correct okay and before you keep going
i want to back up for anybody listening
to this
it is not quote-unquote prying
to get full disclosures of medical
issues and mental health issues of
personal challenges
of past history you are the idea of
marriage is to become one
you are hitching yourself to somebody
else and saying right or die until this
thing to the wheels fall off this thing
it is not prying it is not like hey
digging in
it's not hey you can tell me on your own
time man you gotta talk
you gotta talk to each other man um sure
and if you're on the other side of this
and you're with somebody and you're
dating somebody or you're thinking about
it
you got to be honest you got to tell the
truth otherwise
you become you're it's not just my
personal thing it's deceitful
you're lying you're not telling truth
and i know that's hard to wrap your head
around
um the woman you love but wow and um
okay so
you things get so bad you gotta call mom
and then what happens
she went on to tell me that she is uh a
clinically diagnosed
um with bipolar type one okay um
she has a personality disassociative
disorder
um a moodle ability kind of the same
thing in that same category and then
severe anxiety and depression
okay um she does have substantial
bash traumas um molestation by family
members and then when she
uh reported it to her parents her
parents basically told her she was a
liar
um she has
a lot of traumas that in her past and
the long short of it is that in the
beginning i was you know
so confused and i was not a deloney
disciple at that point
and being a critical care paramedic and
a firefighter
i did what i'd say the more i hear your
show most
guys do who have the best of intentions
is i tried to
fix it try to go solve it that's right
yeah yeah
and i really had the best of intentions
and it just was not what she needed and
i didn't know that at the time
and that's hurts my heart that i maybe
furthered her
um her state at the time um
i wish i could say that was all all the
problems that we had aside from the
fights and the ups and downs of bipolar
people don't realize
people say all the time just friends of
you know not friends of mine just people
around like oh my
spouse has bipolar but i mean i think
there's a
big misconception about what bipolar is
especially when someone is
bipolar type one it's one of the most
over
um over diagnosed
diagnostics there is it's just a
catch-all it's become just a catch-all
and when you're actually around somebody
that truly has
t1 bipolar you go oh there it is
right it's tough it's tough yeah it's
very hard on everybody
um you said there's other other things
going on what else happened
well um there was uh
in the fights and back and forth and
this correlates back to me of
she felt like i wasn't there for her or
i wasn't um
being what she needed in these
situations so it caused her to
venture out of our marriage on two
separate occasions
and it was early on in our marriage um
she
in retrospect told me she was very
unhappy and all these different things
so two different affairs essentially can
like back to back
over the course of like a four and a
half or five month period
um and that was in the beginning of last
year
um the end of 2019 beginning of 2020.
yeah she said it was never anything
physical and i actually do believe her
we've had a lot of
counseling and therapy back and forth
over it um but it was
when any time the person you love goes
somewhere else for
satisfaction even if it's just emotional
satisfaction it's
it's a hard pill to swallow yeah
that is i'll go ahead top it all off i
gotta hear this one
um so it just was in it was
after talking i've been in therapy
pretty much the whole time since it
seems like it was
as a result not necessarily as a result
these things were definitely weighing on
her about her feeling
terrible about herself um she
attempted uh suicide uh last year
uh in june of last year yeah i'm sorry
uh so we just had the one year
anniversary of it and um
uh it's been it's been a really really
hard two years yeah
and really the reason why i'm calling is
not to i feel like i'm
uh venting or complaining and i'm not
it's
i'm more calling for encouragement
because so often we hear
a verse and i have it written on my fire
helmet underneath the brim of my fire
helmets that man knows no
greater love than this that one would
lay down his life for another
and my whole life especially being a
firefighter for the past
17 years i have
always thought about that as literally
laying down your life or someone dying
for someone else but
god's almost put on my heart that you
can lay down your life
on a daily basis for someone and like i
said earlier i'd
choose her for better for worse would i
leave her if her
if her diagnosis or her illness was
cancer or
some other debilitating disease i would
never so why would i consider that
in a mental illness situation so uh
i'm more calling for encouragement or
you know when the days get hard
yeah so number one
yeah yeah it's real hard man and so
first thanks for
sharing that and for those people who
live with somebody or love
somebody who's got bipolar
there's not going to be a dry eye on
this call because they've lived what
you're going through
and so here's a couple of things to step
back and
you may know this but hopefully i can
say it really clear for you
um when you've got somebody who suffered
physical abuse sexual abuse especially
at the hands of loved ones
the reason that is so evil
is it makes the only thing that can keep
somebody well which is relationships
it becomes the weapon so her brain has
been scanning her environment for the
last 20 years
30 years looking for somebody trying to
get close to her
so that she can sound the alarm so that
person can never get hurt
and never hurt her again and now that
person is you
right and so there's part of her brain
that knows you're the safest most loving
most wonderful person on planet earth
and there's a part of her brain deep
inside that says get away from this guy
this is going to happen again
and it's going to happen again and it's
going to happen again right
that's what trauma does and when folks
stepping out on me on relationships
marriages that's a common thing with
bipolar one
right you probably were told that in
therapy
sexual acting out addiction just running
and running and running and running
until
somebody collapses and then not running
right
just like the whole world is paused um
it is
hard does she have medical care she
taken her medication
yeah she's been great about it she has
fought
hard over the course of the past year i
think the suicide i mean she did a
she she scared everyone including
herself with her suicide attempt she
she meant it when she tried it wasn't
like one of those things to cry for
attention in any way she so it scared
her and she has worked
tirelessly over the courses we both have
we i have
not only fallen in love with your
program you've helped me more than
you can like i'd ever put into words
just with the tools that you keep
putting in my toolbox but i appreciate
that man she is
and we but she's been seeing uh her uh
clinical psychologist as well as
i'm sorry clinical psychiatrist pardon
me as well as our psychologist that we
both see independently and together
good so here's here's the things that
you're going to need to do
okay okay and it's going to sound
counterintuitive
but you are going to have to really work
hard
on making sure you're okay
think of yourself as a stake in the
ground
into bedrock okay and you are married to
somebody who on
some parts of that month and you'll know
what i'm talking about
loves you with an intensity that people
only dream about
when it's good it's real good isn't it
it's the best
you're the most incredible person who's
ever lived right
maybe this is a terrible analogy and so
i hope the internets don't beat me up
for this
it's kind of like a tetherball and you
were that
you were the pole and you married a
a bird who is constantly flying all over
the place but she's tethered to you
and sometimes man it is the greatest and
sometimes it feels like you're
the whole thing's gonna fall over right
yeah and i said tetherball and bird i
realized that doesn't all work out
together but
um you've got to be that rock in that
center which what does that mean
it means you got to be diligent about
taking care of your physical body you
got to exercise and i know you're a
fireman i know you all do that
you got to be really diligent about
having guy friends in your life
other men who will hold you accountable
who will laugh with you
who will you go get a drink with you can
just go be with right
you have to be really really diligent
about continuing to
um take care of your mental and
spiritual self right have people in your
life whether that's a counselor whether
that's a good pastor or whatever that
looks like for you
and then you're gonna have to just soak
up the great great times and then you're
gonna have to default to routine and
practice when things get hard
and i love your spirit you're in it
sounds like you were in it all in it
and then you're going to have to be able
to hold your wife accountable
she's got to take her medication i've
seen some really remarkable success
stories with folks who will continue to
take their meds
and it's hard when things get really
good for a season man it's easy to stop
taking your meds and that's when you've
got to double down and make sure you're
still taking them
um and people who with bipolar they
really really miss the high parts
because it feels so good right and right
y'all are gonna have to be in that part
together but yeah you've anchored
yourself to a hurricane which is great
and
hard and messy and it's going to come
down to you taking care of you
that's hard it's real hard
we have five kids students
i don't really get much of a break say
that you have five kids
we do together
uh no she has too biological from her
previous marriage i have two biological
from my previous marriage and we haven't
adopted one between us
you all adopted a kid too yes sir
when did y'all do that what does the
last two years been like for y'all
a little bit of a wild ride what are you
doing
ah man john you're my hero today
yeah you don't get much of a break you
know what that means it means you
absolutely have to have a break
okay and you're gonna have to do
something that firefighters do not like
to do
you're gonna have to ask for help
and you're gonna have to demonstrate for
your kids all five of them
that the best way you can love other
people is to love yourself first
to make sure you're healthy first
right yes sir and you know this from
being a fireman you're of no good to a
people in a burning building you're no
good in an ems situation if you haven't
slept
and if you're not feeling good and if
you're not thinking clear right
how much more important than it is for
your kids right that means you're gonna
have to have somebody come over and take
care of those kids while you go work
out and you're gonna have to have
somebody come over if you need to sleep
if you and your wife need to go on a
date
it's gonna have to be part of your life
a regular regular part
but i'll tell you this those guys those
kids won the lottery with you as dad
your wife won the lottery that you're
gonna have to have places where you can
go
lay down and be vulnerable too at some
point if you are
so strong all the time that's that that
poll is going to snap
right yeah i feel it coming to be honest
with you
okay then what do you got to do
it's just is it the hard part i mean i
get the concept it's just
where do i find that time is i just
scares me
what do you got to do just take care of
myself
so where are you going to find the time
you just have to
you just have to be intentional about it
and do it
that's exactly right how old are your
kids
[Music]
uh seven eight nine ten
thirteen awesome they are old enough now
that you can bring them in here's what i
want y'all to do as a family
this is going to be fun you probably
heard me tell other people this
but this is going to be good for your
soul and for theirs i want you all to go
to michael's like some crafty store
and i want you to get a hobby lobby one
of those kind of stores i want you to
get a
a giant canvas is your wife an artist
she actually does like it a lot yes yeah
a lot of folks at bipolar
find a lot of peace in art i want you
all to also get some stick on letters
and i want you all to create the family
values of your new family
here's who we are here's how we treat
each other we do
we do hard work we do hard things we do
chores we treat each other with respect
and i want you all to paint it i want
you to have a family event as you all
come up together
all seven of you god almighty seven
people
bro all seven of you and i want you all
to create this together
i want you to hang it somewhere in the
living room and i want your wife to
play a key role in the artistry of this
and the peacemaking of i want i want all
of you all to be a part of this
here's who we are and then i want you to
begin to
roll off tasks and chores to these kids
let them know that they play a
cornerstone role in this house
whether that's dishes whether that's
making breakfast for one another and for
the family
whether that's helping with dinner prep
whether that's helping with yard prep
whether it's helping you and your side
job because all firemen i know have side
jobs
all they're going to play a key role and
what that's going to allow you to do is
a
teach them responsibility autonomy
strength resilience
they're going to learn words at that
meeting on how to help mom when mom's
not doing well
how to to lean on you
and not on mom during those hard seasons
and how to lean on mom and not on you
when you're having hard seasons and as a
fireman you will
and then you're going to begin to create
space and you're going to lead the way
for that family saying
i need one hour a day to go work out
i need one hour a day to journal to do
prayer time to do
meditation time because this is when i
take care of me
and that means you all are going to take
care of each other you're going to
model that for them and they're going to
hold you accountable like my
two little kids hold me accountable dad
you probably go exercise you're kind of
being
grumpy today and you're gonna build it
and build it and build it
and then you're gonna have a group of
guys that you reach out to and you tell
your kids
daddy's gonna go be with his friends
tonight they're all old enough to stay
at home by themselves now
and you're going to step out you're
going to
model that you're going to model
friendships you're going to model taking
care of yourself
you're going to model taking care of
your wife when it gets hard
loving like crazy when it's good
and you know this better than i do there
it's not an easy road
it can be a deep and rich and fertile
road but it won't be an easy one
and dude you say that um
i'm some kind of hero i'm not brother
you're the hero here
you're doing the hard work i just talk
on the podcast
you're doing the hard work day in and
day out and for all first responders out
there
i used to show up on scenes it's way
easier to show up on a scene and help
somebody else
than it is to do the day-to-day grind in
your own home
it's way easier
every first responder i know it's easier
to show up at a car wreck it's easier to
show up in a burning building it's
easier to show up in a tragic situation
than to be patient and kind on a daily
basis that's hard
we can do this you all can do this thank
you so much for your call brother john
we're thinking about you let us know how
i can help as we
as you make this journey with your wife
and your five kids
you're in it